Let's try to do this in a general way now. Right. So we call this procedure down heapify.
Let's talk about how we actually will go with this.
I've made a couple of helpful routines to help with the heap.
given a position i in the heap, left (i) returns the position of the left child.
Right (i )returns the position of the right child. Parent (i) returns the position of the parent.
Root (i) answers whether or not the node that we're talking about is a root.
There's no root. Leaf (L, i) returns whether or not we're looking at a leaf (i).
In other words, it has no children.
It has no children if what where the right child would be is off the end of the list
and where the left child would be is off the end of the list.
Then there's one other special kind of node and there can be at most
one of these in the whole tree and that's a one_child node.
That happens if a node has a left child, which is the very last element in the array.
The right child doesn't exist.
That's just what I said that the right child is at the very end of the list
or off the end of the list then that's a one_child node.
Down heapify is this notion that we've got.
We apply this in the notion where we've got a heap rooted at node i that satisfies
the heap property except perhaps i to its children, to its immediate children.
We can apply this if the heap property is satisfied.
Everywhere except maybe between the root and its kids,
so the root in particular the node i and its kids.
Let's just say that. If i is actually a leaf, then we're done. Right.
We're satisfied everywhere except for between i and its children,
and i doesn't have any children.
So, good. That's great. Heap property is restored.
If i has only one child, then we need to think a little harder.
In the case where i has one child, we check the heap property
between i and its one child on the left and if i is bigger than its child that's bad.
That means the heap property isn't satisfied but all we have to do to fix it is
we just swap the value in the left child and i.
That's what we did and then now we know that that last node
is the very last node in the tree and that node we just swapped into
is the very last node in the tree so it must be that things are happy everywhere.
What if i has two children? So this is some internal node in the tree now.
Or possibly a root of a large tree. So now we check the heap property.
I'm going to do this this way. I'm going to ask look at the left and the right children,
and look at the minimum value of those two.
If the minimum value is bigger than or equal to L[i] that means L[i]
the value at node i is smaller than both the kids so we're good.
The heap property is satisfied everywhere and we can just return.
On the other hand, sadly if that doesn't hold, then we need to see which child is the smallest
or the smaller of the two and swap i's value into that child.
That's just what we're doing in the example by hand.
Let's check it. If the left child is smaller than the right child,
that means that the left child is the smallest one.
We swap i and the left child's value and then we need to down heapify on the left child.
We've basically fixed things everywhere except for possibly the tree rooted at left (i).
It could actually not satisfy the heap property but that's okay.
We can fix that by bubbling down the tree with down heapify once again.
It's just what we did when we're doing it by hand and then we can return.
Finally, we reached this point, if the heap property is violated and the right child of i
is between i and the right child of i so we can just swap i and the right child of i
possibly causing the tree rooted at the right child of i to be violated.
We just run down heapify starting from there. When that's done, we can return.
And we've established the heap property throughout the tree.